[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is our robotic garden.
The inspiration behind
it was that there
isn't a lot of
interest, especially
from young girls
in computer science
and not a great way for
them to get interested.
And the garden is a
great way to teach
some of these basic concepts
in a visually pleasing way.
We have over 100 different
robotic flowers in this garden.
And they can all open and close.
And the LED-lit flowers
can also change colors.
So we can show distributed
algorithms running
on the garden as
well and demonstrate
some basic algorithm
concepts for beginning
computer scientists.
You can interact with the
garden through the computer.
We have an interface that shows
the garden split up into tiles.
And you can click on a
tile and click on a color
and the flowers on that
tile will change colors
or you can make them
inflate or deflate.
And we also have buttons
to display the distributed
algorithms that can
run in the garden.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the more
interesting algorithms
that we can run on the garden
is called graph coloring.
And so what happens
in graphic coloring
is every tile will
have flowers that
are a different color
from the flowers
on every tile around it.
And we need at most 4 colors
to accomplish this here.
Recently we displayed the
garden at the Hour of Code.
And we had some local
high school students
come and try out the garden.
And then when they saw the
code run in the garden,
kids were really excited.
And one of the
really neat things
that happened as a result
of the Hour of Code
was I had a couple of
kids come up and ask me
where they could get their
own components to make
their own robotic systems
and how to get started.
And so it really was doing
what we were hoping it would,
which is inspiring
kids to get interested
in robotics and programming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]